Sam nunberg
and after Sam nunberg be Ziad Ramadan
ladies and gentlemen of the landmark
commission my name is Sam nummberg I'm
Deputy political director of the
American Center for Law and Justice and
my parents own property at 57 Warren
Street at 8 45 a.m on 9 11 my uncle
heard a whisp outside his window when he
saw American Airlines flight 11 hit
Tower one's Northern facade Muhammad
atta's hijacked planes wheel flew from
the impact and landed in 4547 Park Place
ladies and Gentlemen The Landmark
commission what is going on here today
the board by law is Duty bound not to
act in any manner that is arbitrary or
capricious yet after sitting on this
Landmark application since 1989 suddenly
after an application to erect the
cardova mosque it appears that the board
is clearing the depths and ramming this
matter through for political expediency
the landmark in this building is
important not only to maintain the
character of the neighborhood and to
preserve the unique architectural design
that would otherwise be lost but also
because of the tragic events of 9 11. it
is important to Grant The Landmark
status in order to freeze construction
of buildings that do not belong at the
location and would irreparably change
the look of the neighborhood not only
has the building stood there for over
150 years it has also felt the impact of
the 9 11 attack unlike any other
building in the area if this commission
felt it appropriate to Landmark 11 West
18th Street
because Bill airs whether underground
had a terrorist malfunction incident
then 45-47 Park Place surely deserves
Landmark status due to the impact of the
Wheel from atta's hijacked American
Airlines flight 11. it would be a
travesty to permit this building to be
removed it would be like removing the
sunken ship from Pearl Harbor to a
Rector memorial for the Japanese
kamikazes killed in the attack
just as All Eyes Of The Nation were
looking intently on this neighborhood
immediately after the attack of
September 11 2001 rest assured that the
power of the aclj will make sure that
the nation are National members from
across all 50 states will follow the
manner in which this commission will act
to either preserve the character of 4547
Park Place or to permit changes that
will blot out memories and then our
national psyche thank you
thank you thank you very much
Ziad Ramadan
and let me call five more names so we
can get uh set up if possible Valerie
loose nikowska
Roman Shusterman
there's another Jack Lester apparently
from 261 Madison if I'm not mistaken and
then Robert Spencer
and Andrea Quinn anyway and I'll call
them again but please if you've heard
your name go to one of the two mics
Ramadan good afternoon thank you good
afternoon honorable Commission
I'm speaking as a congregant since uh
the Inception of the completed sale of
the building
as a proud American I I enjoy my first
amendment rights to freedom of worship
some tidbits that I think that the
commission should know uh that was a
hard act to follow but I can't say that
my wife was a first responder
at 9 11 and she built the triage centers
and she built the pharmacies and the USS
Mercy
thanked her for creating order out of
the chaos in order to help her fellow
First Responders my brother was a first
responder as well
I was establishing uh I was with
Columbia University's emergency rooms I
was helping to establish
a food and Pantry setup because we knew
the whole island was sealed off and the
Food suppliers would not be able to help
the hospitals but most importantly
as a chair as a former chair of my
community board in Manhattan
I am I'm familiar with the nature of
these proceedings
though the community board one has not
finalized its resolution the committee
is unanimously
rejected the denotation of this building
as a landmark we have a word that I'm
sure you're very familiar with and
that's contextual
the nature of this building would not be
contextual to the surrounding community
but I'm not going to go into the
technicalities because that's your
expertise
I just want you to know
that as Americans
it would be defying what our soldiers
are fighting for what our founding
fathers created and what this
constitution
promises all of us that's the freedom of
religion if we start picking and
choosing where what house of holy
worship should be on which street
we're opening up a can of worms that
will be a huge mess for us as Americans
one last note
a lot of the rhetoric that you're
hearing
about not here not at Ground Zero
anywhere else
it's the same thing that's happening in
Staten Island it's the same thing that's
happening in Brooklyn
and everybody's saying no it's called
islamophobia pure and simple and do not
allow please please let them speak yes
to include
ouch you see if this is if this is the
voice if this is the voice of reason
okay then we've got a lot to contend
with thank you very much thank you very
much Valerie
Valerie losing
uh sorry did you call Roman shieldsman
then I'm going to call Robert Spencer my
name is Valerie luchnikovska next and I
hope you bear with me while I read this
statement because I am a member I lost
my nephew in the World Trade Center and
I am a member of a group called
September 11 families for peaceful
tomorrows all of whom lost someone in
the events of that day and some of my
colleagues are sitting right here
um thank you for this opportunity to
address the commission and others here
who are interested in preserving the
Heritage and beauty of our city
I was executive director of the Congress
of modern Architects for six years
as someone who lost a family member in
the 9 11 attacks on the World Trade
Center I also have a keen interest in
the area as do my colleagues who are
sitting here the building at issue here
45 to 47 Park Place is representative of
the Italian style of architecture a
handsome building but not unique they
are a myriad better examples of the
Antebellum Italian at style in areas
including Tribeca Soho the Lower East
Side Red Hook Brooklyn and Williamsburg
this landmarking proposal was calendared
by the LPC years ago with reason the
current proposal to demolish the
building to make way for a Muslim
Community Center Cordoba house has
prompted the commission to examine
whether or not to move ahead with a
landmark designation at this point
the possibility of giving Landmark
status to the building in question has
been in the hopper for 21 years partly
postponed by the opposition of the
Burlington Coat Factory Corporation its
former tenant and partly because the
building is just not worth the
designation as as it is not unique and
no longer part of a surrounding
architectural grouping
similar buildings law nearby have long
been replaced and overshadowed by
skyscrapers and many other substantial
communities of this architectural type
still exists elsewhere as I formally
stated
for these reasons the landmarking
proposal has languished at the
commission with no active proponents to
bring it to the fore I completely
support Landmark status for good
examples of architectural styles that
represent various areas of development
in New York City
but it is the opinion of many Architects
that there needs to be a consistency in
how that status is granted with a
plethora of this type of design still
extant in the city individual buildings
like this should be Landmark preferably
where they still exist in groups to
convey the sense of the community in its
time
therefore I urge the commission to make
their decision based on the true merits
of the design which in this case is not
extraordinary
many of us myself and other 911 family
survivors here with me in the audience
who love lost loved ones right there at
the site urge you to work with the
Muslim Center to find the best solution
for keeping any of the building features
you deem significant while recognizing
the immense value of the community
center as planned to all the residents
of lower yeah thank you very much Mr
Spencer Robert Spencer
yes I would like to Echo one of the
earlier speakers who failed to
understand the relevance of uh these
statements about the Muslim American
community and their love for America and
their value to the community and so on
but as long as those statements are
relevant in the landmarks hearing and I
think also relevant is the support of
the Imam Faisal Abdul rauf for Sharia
law which institutionalizes
discrimination against women and
religious minorities and which uh
please let us which denies the freedom
of speakers
and also his refusal to denounce Hamas
as a terrorist group his support for the
Jihad flotilla that was trying to
smuggle arms into Israel his statements
that dissembled about his support for
religious dialogue speaking in favor of
religious dialogue to American audiences
but then saying to Arabic audiences that
he opposed religious dialogue and also
his uh disassembling about the funding
that he was receiving in saying that he
was only receiving funding from American
Muslim sources to the American Press but
to the arabic speaking press saying he
was receiving funding from various
Muslim groups can you excuse me these
things we need to hear you so if if
people would please respect yeah I
appreciate that uh these things are uh
all as much as of a matter of record for
what kind of a building this is going to
be and what it's going to do in lower
Manhattan as these Bland statements of
uh Civic uh virtue are from the Muslims
who have spoken here so far uh if uh if
it's bigotry to say that this guy is
lying to us well then call it what you
want but if he's lying to us and he's
going to make a uh a subversive group
that a subversive institution that is
spreading subversion in lower Manhattan
that would seem to be part of your
responsibility to to consider also it's
very interesting that Ms Mr riddle said
that the building had no unique history
I couldn't help but note that it was the
only building in New York City that the
landing gear from one of the 911 planes
crashed into and that does give it a
unique history and uh
lend support for the idea already
enunciated here that this building and
the surrounding area should be a war
memorial and that that would be probably
the best designation for it thank you
very much okay thank you very much
Andrea Quinn
my name is Andrea Quinn
the Burlington Coat Factory Building
located at 45 Park Place deserves to be
granted Landmark status
the architectural and cultural
importance of this building must not and
cannot be denied the plan to build a
16-story mosque on that site is
absolutely ludicrous
New York City is home to many existing
mosques and cultural centers there is no
shortage of mosques in lower Manhattan
or anywhere in New York City
with so few Palazzo style buildings left
in New York City
it is the commission's duty to take
positive action and preserve this piece
of American History it is the
commission's duty to maintain this
architectural style in lower Manhattan
to deprive this building of landmark
status is to allow for a citadel of
Islamic Supremacy to be erected in its
place
nothing could be more negative and
nothing could be more insensitive and
nothing could be more damaging to the
American Spirit
we appeal to you here today
this is your opportunity to show that
the commission has not forgotten the
terrorist attacks of 9 11 that the
commission and the City of New York have
respect and compassion for Humanity this
is your opportunity to take positive
action to send a positive message to the
people of New York and all of America we
implore you to be positive make the
positive decision Grant Landmark status
thank you
thank you thank you very much now I'm
going to call five five more names
please so everybody can hear
Michael hand and now elected officials
are represented here one person I'd like
to call now is Michael Henry Adams who
represents Senator Perkins and then I
understand that Rick Lazio is here he
would speak next and then Roman
Shusterman
Jack the aforementioned Jack Lester
and Sarah Hartman so those five
Mr Adams good afternoon my name is
Michael Henry Adams and I'm representing
state senator Bill Perkins of the 30th
District
I write to you as the senator
representing the 30th District of New
York State widely associated with
historic Harlem but comprising as well
significant portions of East Harlem's
albarel Washington Heights Morningside
Heights in the Upper West Side
no one could logically question my
record as a stalwart preservationist
preserving our history is embodied by
the most exceptional or representative
buildings from the past is certainly one
of the most enduring things that we
politicians do
and Harlem on Washington and Morningside
Heights and elsewhere are remarkable
landmarks law has sometimes been misused
solely for political considerations
Undisputed landmarks like Saint Thomas
the Apostle Roman Catholic church or
Saint Vincent De Paul Roman Catholic
Church have not been properly protected
this is wrong
and similarly now when 100 when 152 year
old Burlington Coat Factory building at
45 Park Place
first proposed for designation 20 years
ago
has finally gotten a hearing there is a
question raised as to whether or not the
law is being misused in a different kind
of way
this is not for me to determine
however with Mayor Michael Bloomberg a
Manhattan Borough president Scott
Stringer I join in welcoming an
opportunity for the creation of a new
house of worship in our city
the proposed mosque and social Center
exemplify an element of the diversity
and cultural richness
that makes New York the best city in
America the greatest Nations
no other place
no other place has the strength of
forging a single unit out of so many
different peoples
no building better than the one in
Vision demonstrates the extent of our
position of Tolerance and strength with
Justice and opportunity for all thank
you thank you very much Rick Lazio
thank you Mr chairman I thought I would
thank you and the members of the
commission for giving me the opportunity
to testify before you I appreciate the
work that you're doing
Mr chairman I urge this commission to
Grant Landmark status to 45 Park Place
for more than 20 years for more than 20
years the application for landmark
status says stood in limbo while over
those many years since 1989 this issue
has been calendared and yet adjourned
repeatedly tabling the issue
now it seems as though the commission is
being asked to rush through its decision
about the historical importance of this
building and I ask that before you make
this decision that you take into account
certain important historical facts
just seven months ago as you know this
commission decided that 311 Broadway a
building just blocks away from 45 Park
Place was considered a historical
landmark and granted that status this
decision was made because it was one of
the few remaining Palazzo style Italian
Renaissance buildings left in New York
yet Mr chairman 45 Park Place also fits
this description
is located in the same neighborhood and
is only one block south of the South
Tribeca historic district
if you look at these two buildings it is
not difficult to see the Striking
resemblance between this architecture
so if 311 Broadway is a landmark why not
45 Park Place
Mr chairman the theme the famed
architect Daniel Badger designed 45 Puck
place and a number of his buildings as
you know have already been granted
Landmark status by the city further 40
45 Park Place was the headquarters of
Merck and Company for 14 years from 1911
to 1925 the pharmaceutical Giant and of
course as others have testified before
me on September 11th the building itself
was damaged by the landing gear of one
of the planes that struck the Trade
Center the Twin Towers it was part of
the attack a place of deep historical
significance and a reminder just of what
happened on New York's Darkest Day
it has also come to my attention Mr
chairman the 45 Park places status as a
historical landmark has not received
full a full vote from the community
board number one
it is only appropriate that the full
commit Community Board review this
Landmark application before any action
by this commission until the full
community board has addressed this
matter this commission should not decide
on the landmark status of 45 Park Place
finally Mr chairman it's not lost on me
the limitations of the jurisdiction of
this commission and considering other
issues outside of the historical
importance of the building but I will
say it's impossible to consider this
without understanding the context of
what we're asking for a delay in the
process to allow us to get answers to
some very critical questions
who is the spearhead of this proposal in
fact has said some incredibly incendiary
controversial things this is somebody
who has created uh controversy by saying
effectively that America and American
policy was the accessory to the crime of
9 11. he is somebody who's been tied to
some of the most militant International
organizations this is a time when we
need to ask serious questions that will
keep the people of New York and
particularly the people of downtown
Manhattan feeling and actually being
safe this is no small matter this is a
proposal
for a one a 100 million dollar mosque
and I would ask that again in the
context of this of this decision that
you give people a time to have these
questions answered thank you thank you
very much
okay
Roman Schusterman
please quiet Roman Schuster yeah I'm
over here over here there you go and
then Jack Lester excuse me well I'm in
Sarah Hartman just give me give me a
minute okay uh my name is Roman
Schusterman yeah I'm from the Coney
Island area I'm an activist for a while
um
yeah I know the sign's getting a lot of
attention because there's a lot of
there's a lot of tension in the room so
I wanted to you know make a little bit
more
um you know a little less tension
there's a lot of fighting there's a lot
of fighting over this building all these
bricks and everyone's so passionate
about this building personally
at first I was actually against uh the
mosque in the beginning because I
thought Bloomberg was trying to use it
as some sort of political issue to try
to get Muslim votes but now it appears
that it's not just the mosque in
Manhattan it's people protesting mosque
in general and protesting Muslims in
general now the problem with that is
the problem with that is that if if our
if our country's so great and our
culture is so great why do we need to
you know be so angry and violently be uh
protesting Muslims if you know I think
that
please let him speak now let everyone
speaks something in here
please
even if there are a lot of Muslim
terrorists which there are I'm not
saying there aren't I'm just saying
we're in America right isn't this our
country
continue continue to see what's special
about that building so so this meeting
is about is this meeting about
landmarking or is this meeting about
Muslims because this paper said it's
about landmarking right all right so if
it's about landmarking but people aren't
here not to discuss landmarking then I
want to discuss my issue which is
pre-happy endings okay so you know since
we're gonna just discuss random issues
that's what I think is going to make the
world better look Al Gore had a problem
right you know maybe if you don't have
to pay for it you know everyone can have
a good time we could all get together
and everyone will have tastes all right
that's that's my point thank you very
much Jack is Jack Lester the other Zach
Lester as I call him here
if not Sarah Hartman
and Sarah if you'd bear with me one
moment before you begin I want to call
also to
uh Kate McNutt Rachel Busan
and Barbara summer to sort of get ready
if you would thank you please good
afternoon my name is Sarah Hartman
um actually based on your study of the
architectural and historical
significance of 4547 Park Place Building
I'm kind of surprised that you haven't
already designated as a landmark status
I think that a lot of reasons that have
already been presented by some of the
other speakers clearly indicate that it
should be and I do feel that it would be
a terrible mistake to destroy a 154 year
old building in order to build a a
monument to terrorism and that actually
disrespects the lives of those who have
been lost and our culture and history of
freedom in this country and there are
plenty of places where mosques can be
built and I have nothing to against
mosque being built but I think this is a
terrible mistake at this particular site
which should be designated as a
historical area and a sacred area to
destroy a building of landmark status or
the quality of that kind of a building
for these purposes and there's no you
know there's peaceful Islam it's not
about being Islam having islamophobia
but there are definitely different sects
of Islam and I've realized that the
commission is not concerned with the
future of whatever would happen to this
site but as an American citizen and as a
resident of Manhattan I am concerned
about what could happen and there are
jihadists Islam
islamists and there are peaceful just uh
islamists and there's no way of knowing
what this particular Center you know
which sect is going to dominate is true
of any other place but there's freedom
of religion and speech and everything
else here that's why we have this this
wonderful opportunity to speak but I am
concerned about it not
um
that this Moss being built at this
particular site that should be declared
as a whole historic site
thank you very much